jetzt ist deutschunterricht angesagt war
erstklässlern wie frido ist das
homeschooling besonders schwierig sie
müssen ja erst mal die grundlagen lernen
zusammen mit seiner mutter lernt viel
lesen und schreiben im wohnzimmer das
findet er griff auch ganz gut
dann lassen wir nicht zu viert also mit
seiner kleinen schwester toni der großen
schwester selber und ihrer mutter
so ist immer was los gespielt dass wir
die schulkantine sind vielleicht aus dem
meer gekommen ist und dann haben wir so
getan haben wir für toni dass das die
drei schüler der schule schaffen fast
nie das was eigentlich so für einen tag
vorgesehen wäre ich wollte sie lehrerin
werden und ich weiß nicht wie man
jemanden dazu bringt irgendwie 27 mal
hintereinander dass es zu schreiben
friedas lehrerin an theresa schmid und
einer verdanke geben ihr bestes die
kinder und ihre eltern digital zu
unterstützen von ihren privaten laptops
aus mehrmals die woche gibt es daher
sprech und fragestunden per video aber
sechsjährigen schreiben lesen und
rechnen beizubringen das ist digital
schwierig manche kinder die welt einfach
gar nicht erreichen können die die die
lern jetzt sehr wenig aber wir versuchen
die dann in die schule zu holen und hier
was mit ihnen zu machen
genau die die einfach zu hause wir nicht
lernen können aufgrund der anzahl der
geschwister und des raumes und immerhin
die tablets die der berliner senat
stellt können jetzt an kinder verteilt
werden die keine digitalen geräte zu
hause haben experten sagen auch das
hätte früher kommen müssen die schulen
sind technisch nicht besser ausgestattet
als im märz letzten jahres die
lehrkräfte haben sich selber individuell
technik angeschafft haben sich schlau
gemacht mit welcher technik funktioniert
funktioniert das gut aber die
bildungsverwaltung haben eine menge
verschlafen
aufgrund der hohen infektionszahlen in
berlin bleibt diese schule er
einmal geschlossen zurück bei mirja
gerard dou sie ist gerade in elternzeit
ihr mal arbeitet zu kriegen sie das mit
dem homeschooling irgendwie hin also
dass man daneben arbeiten könnte es den
absolute illusion also wenn ich
irgendwas in die welt tragen will dann
ist das ist unmöglich ist home office
und kumpel hinzu kommen die hier
es ist eine ausnahmesituation das wissen
die lehrer denken trotzdem dass bald
wieder ein wenig normalität in ihren
alltag zurückkehrt